[Music]
when I was six my family moved to the
city of Hyderabad and Vivek was my new
neighbor
he quickly became one of my closest
friends he and I would run along the
road we play soccer in the evenings and
race our bikes down the nearby hill at
that age I thought we had a lot in
common but our lives couldn't have been
more different I lived with my family in
a small brick apartment with running
water and electricity Vivek lived in the
field next door in a tiny Shack made out
of thin sheets and tarpaulin for water
Vivek and his sisters would walk a mile
every day to collect it from the tank at
night they would burn wood scraps to
keep themselves warm and cook while I
was in school learning about history
math and science
Vivek would spend his days collecting
wood and water for his family while I
had the benefit of clean air at home his
home was surrounded by thick grey smoke
from the burning wood I really wanted to
help with it but I didn't know how so I
asked my mother and to my surprise she
offered to pay for his school and even
found one that he could go to but his
family had to decline our offer their
lack of access to energy meant that
Vivek had to stay at home and help his
family I was 10 when I first learned
that there simply wasn't enough energy
to go around when I wasn't playing with
Vivek and other friends during the
school year I would often visit my uncle
Moe Hans rice farm just like over half
the farmers in the country
his family lived off a small plot of
land about the size of an average
McDonald's parking lot in India the
government offers free electricity to
all farmers but that promised
electricity is extremely unreliable
because of this sometimes he couldn't
pump enough water to his crops other
times if the pumps were left on the
crops would be flooded either way this
meant that he would end up having to
discard about half of his rice supply
each season and without enough rice to
sell
he couldn't send my cousin's to better
schools or afford health care again I
wanted to help but I didn't know how it
seemed that there simply wasn't enough
energy to go around at that age I
couldn't help we wake or my uncle but as
I grew older I became determined to help
others like them at college I studied
energy systems after college I worked
for a large energy company and I learned
a lot from these experiences I learned
that we wake is one of 2 billion
children who rely on dirty sources of
energy 2 billion children who breathe in
dirty air and face asthma and other
chronic lung diseases 2 billion children
who are unable to go to school because
they have to collect scraps of wood 2
billion who do not have the opportunity
to rise out of poverty I also learnt
that my uncle is among hundreds of
millions of farmers who struggle to make
ends meet because of an unreliable
energy supply the scale of this problem
is daunting but this isn't the first
time that we've enabled large-scale
change think about the mobile banking
revolution in Africa
for decades millions of Africans did not
have access to banking services they
couldn't hold money in an account they
couldn't transfer funds and they did not
have access to credit but a few
innovative companies realized that while
they didn't have access to banks they
did have cell phones and this started a
revolution millions of families now have
access to financial services even in
remote parts of the developing world
access that has dramatically changed
their lives and help them rise out of
poverty what we did for access to
financial services we need to do for
energy mobile banking started with the
simple idea that traditional banks need
not be the only solution for financial
access we need to find similar no Bank
solutions for energy and apply those
learnings first we must identify the
real need for financial services the
need was not for a traditional bank but
for an easy way to transfer funds and
have access to credit for energy we need
to identify those fundamental needs and
under and build innovative solutions
around them the company embrace founded
by Stanford Business School alum
understood this for parents with
premature babies the real need was not
for expensive energy intensive
incubators in city hospitals they simply
needed a way to keep their babies warm
so embrace came up with an at-home
low-cost infant warmer saving over a
hundred thousand lives in the process
when it comes to energy access we need
more companies like embrace which
understand those fundamental needs and
build innovative solutions around them
second
we need to use existing technology to
address these needs we have so much
amazing technology here that we simply
need to find a way to apply it to the
developing world take fly bird for
example this company co-opted
decades-old sensor technology to build a
device that regulates the amount of
water and fertilizer that's delivered to
a crop this device solves the exact need
that my uncle had and is built on
existing technology when it comes to
energy access
we need companies like fly bird which
build solutions on existing platforms
lastly we need to start solving small
local problems and not just large
systemic ones mobile banking started by
creating solutions for families not
countries if we had waited for mobile
mobile banking and just banking services
to expand we would have lost the
opportunity to serve a whole generation
of the population systemic change is
slow but small-scale change can start
today micro grids are a great example of
one such solution these grids are built
in remote areas and provide energy
access to small communities a whole
series of such no Bank solutions can
help Vivek and other families like their
homes and send their kids to school it
can help my uncle and other farmers earn
a living wage this change is possible
let's make it happen because the truth
is there is enough energy to go around
we simply need to find the right way to
get it there
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]